and finally new rule and this one goes
out to all the new college grads you
don't need to get a sheepskin you need
to get a thick skin this year marks the
first graduating class of Generation Z
the first generation to grow up on cell
phones and iPads and devices which many
have said parents use as pacifiers now
in another era parents used actual
pacifiers and one one fell on the floor
they pick it up and stick it right back
in your mouth
I'm no doctor so I don't know what that
does to a kid's immune system but I do
know this we didn't all have peanut
allergies
if Millennials were the generation with
helicopter parents who hovered over them
Gen Z are the kids with bulldozer
parents who don't just hover but clear
the way of all obstacles for their kids
and since Gen Z is such a special class
I thought they deserved a special
commencement address
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hundred alumni legacy students parents
grandparents deaf parents third wives
and drunk uncle
I know it's traditional at graduations
commencement ceremonies to break the ice
with a joke so here goes a man walks
into a bar of course it doesn't have to
be a man
that's full he could be a woman but then
who am I to write a joke about a female
when I don't have first-hand experience
of a woman's struggle so a non-binary
non gender conforming humanoid walked
into a bar and orders a drink and the
bartender says you took too long we
closed 20 minutes ago
well I see that about 50% of you are
texting so I can tell already this will
be somewhat pointless but it is my job
as your graduation speaker to tell you
that you're a very special group of
young people and the future belongs to
you but let's not kid ourselves you're
not that special and the future belongs
to China and our robot overseas let me
see if I can fake it you're the smartest
you're the best and thanks to that
photography degree you now have you're
gonna change the world now I want you to
look in the gallery today and find your
two best friends mom and dad they're the
ones who worked and sacrificed to scrape
together the half a million in bribes
needed to get you into this thousand
dollar-a-year keg party they call a
college and parents I'm here today to
tell you that the results of your
parenting have been incredible for the
pharmaceutical industry because these
kids are [ __ ] up and need drugs they
need drugs for the crushing levels of
anxiety they have brought on by the
knowledge that after the way you
pampered and spoiled them life is going
to crush them like the white kid in a
spelling bee
I'm just trying to be your friend which
is someone who tells you the truth and
the truth is the world is unfair it's
not like college it's like the electoral
college
and you kids you're about to enter
freshman year of life and that can be
very unsettling what's like the slap in
the face that your parents should have
given you the first time you swore at
them but they didn't they didn't then so
you became the hey buddy generation hey
buddy could you put your shoes on hey
buddy could you get in the car but in
real life not everyone is your [ __ ]
buddy and that's why your [ __ ] no I mean
really [ __ ] because no one ever told you
no or you're wrong or you're in the way
or that's not good enough or wait so you
think the whole world is supposed to be
your safe space where everything is
wonderful and nobody even gets their
feelings hurt well kids I have some very
bad news for you mr. Rogers is dead
[Applause]
and so new graduates as you look back at
where you've been and where you about to
go I want you to turn to your parents
and take this opportunity to tell them
thank you thank you for murdering any
chance I had of actually making it in
the real world thank you for covering
the walls of my childhood room with fake
certificates and fada [ __ ] like
third grade gym super story most
improved finger painter and world
champion paste eater
thank you for trophies I got for just
showing up thank you for the temper
tantrums you let me throw in the cereal
aisle thank you for bitching out every
teacher who ever gave me a B instead of
an A even though I really deserve this C
and thank you for teaching me that any
thought word or action or feelings I had
was unfair which didn't make me a
liberal it made me Donald Trump
you